québec annoncera lundi la réouverture
graduelle des restaurants à partir du 15
juin
il y encore des discussions à savoir si
les restaurants de la région de montréal
pourront ouvrir à cette date ou s'ils
devront attendre encore un peu les
restaurateurs pourront servir des repas
sur les terrasses et en salle à manger
à condition de maintenir une distance
entre leurs clients
c'est extrêmement important de pouvoir
ré ouvrir parce que c'est difficile
d'être d'avoir aucun revenu le pour 50 %
des restaurants qui n'ont pas de service
de livraison et de man a porté ses aucun
revenu depuis le 22 mars
alors ça commence à presser avec nous un
et que baudouin qui est co fondatrice et
propriétaire du restaurant auguste à
sherbrooke bonsoir madame beaudoin
bonsoir comment vous accueillez vous la
nouvelle aujourd'hui de cette
réouverture
fermeture le 22 mars réouverture le 15
juin
comment vous accueillez ça c'est sûr que
c'est un soulagement on a hâte de
retrouver nos activités en fait nos
activités principales
parce qu'on développe d'autres d'autres
façons de fonctionner depuis quelques
mois mais on a besoin de retrouver nos
principales fonctions effectivement et
comment vous avez vécu les 3-11
dernières semaines ben j'ai un mot et
qui s'appelle danser dans l'ombre on
avance on se retrouveront sans voir de
se réajuster donc ça demande énormément
de créativité c'est comme ça qu'on les a
vécus on a commencé par faire des mets
pour apporter aujourd'hui on a ouvert ce
midi un volet cantine sur la rue un peu
sous forme de j'arrive commandes
ils attendent sont des pastilles de m ou
à l'extérieur et ils repartent manger à
l'extérieur avec leur pop
est-ce que vos clients vous sont restés
fidèles et ont été au rendez vous mais
effectivement oui on a eu une bonne je
dirais un appui sympathique de notre
fidèle clientèle mais écoutez c'est pas
le même c'est pas du tout
pour certains de mes clients je sais
qu'ils sont moins enclins à ce genre de
consommation on a eu aussi d'autres
clients qui étaient peut-être jamais
venu chez nous qui ont consommé des
menus pour emporter mais c'est sûr que
l'expérience client est pas là mais
c'est pas la même chose effectivement
est ce que votre chiffre d'affaires a
baissé beaucoup je dirais chuté oui oui
de combien peu près à de près de je
dirais ça ça vacille entre 75 et 80 pour
ça ah oui et donc de donc depuis presque
trois mois vous passer à travers ça mais
pourriez-vous et pourrait vous résister
encore longtemps
ben écoutez c'est sûr qu'avec
l'ouverture des salles à manger des
terrasses on va pouvoir effectivement
poursuivre d'autres activités
mais il faut ce qu'il faut se rappeler
c'est que à 50 % de capacité même à 60
car les deux matches dont 10 50%
capacité des tables de mettre dans mon
corps pour 180 places ça vient avec
quelques places il faut continuer les
activités connexes qu'on a développé
depuis plusieurs mois donc on se
retrouve avec trois entreprises et donc
diriez-vous qu'un modèle d'affaires
possible dans ces circonstances là avec
ce que vous avez développé et en
fonctionnement en fonctionnant avec à
peu près le quart des places assises
dont vous parlez il faut être imaginatif
c'est sûr qu'il va falloir rien parti un
peu la restauration dans mon corps j'ai
un restaurant quand même qu'ils
pouvaient assumer un certain volume
sapin ou le mans c'est une ville
universitaire j'avais plusieurs forfaits
où je pouvais rouler la salle à manger
c'est sûr que c'est une avenue qui est
beaucoup plus compliquée avec la
distanciation et aussi on parle
d'expérience qu'il ya un service souvent
quand les gens vont vouloir
salle à manger ils veulent vivre une
expérience donc pour vivre une
expérience faut pas être pressé faut
avoir faut prendre le temps à table donc
pour nous c'est du temps aussi le temps
c'est l'argent pour vous donc ça nous
demande de revoir la politique de des
menus et ça vous demande toutes sortes
de mesures de distanciation vous avez
prévu des choses à partir de la mi juin
oui tout à fait alors j'ai travaillé
avec une ergonome ça a été d'ailleurs de
d'une grande aide pour ma part parce que
pour moi c'était un peu inconcevable de
commencer à juste de mettre la distance
entre les tables genre en une cuisine
ouverte avec un fond noir où les
cuisiniers sont devant les clients donc
je voulais pas laisser ça à l'est non
plus donc on ne lui a pas voir tout
l'espace et des coûts bon on parle
souvent du festival du plexiglas la
restauration mais effectivement c'est
une dépense faux cloisonné un peu plus
haut niveau ça aussi c'est quand même
quelque chose d infection les mesures
sont pas toutes sorties pour la
réouverture des restaurants mais on
s'est un peu à quoi s'attendre on parle
de un client la fois aux toilettes donc
sa demande d'avoir le personnel
nécessaire pour la désinfection fait
fait douze ans que je me trompe pas que
vous êtes en affaires oui avez-vous
l'impression de recommencer de de
revenir à la case départ
oui je peux vous le confirmer
oui oui parce que c'est sûr que quand ça
fait 12 ans les dépenses les grosses
dépenses sont derrière ont réinvesti ont
fait des nouveaux projets poursuit ce
qui a déjà été établie donc puis si on a
envie de risquer parce que les affaires
c'est toujours toujours quelque chose
mais c'est notre décision et ce qui
arrive en ce moment ce sont des dépenses
c'est un engagement que je n'ai pas
d'idée qui m'arrive comme ça donc
je vais aller contre actifs pour pouvoir
passer cette période-là s'est pas créé
de joie c'est un cri de obligatoires
madame beaudoin ou souhaite bonne chance
merci beaucoup et on vous laisse à vos
préparatifs pour le 15 juin
merci à la prochaine au revoir